President Paul! President Paul!
A couple years ago, Rand Paul ran for president,
and the media asked:
Has the libertarian moment finally arrived?
President Paul! President Paul!
But Paul’s Presidential campaign went nowhere.
RandPaul shouldn’t even be on the stage,
he's number 11; he's got 1% in the polls.
I had high hopes this was
going to be the libertarian moment.
The crowd was cheering.
[Applause]
We have come to take our country back
What happened?
I would say that
either the people aren't ready or perhaps
the people in the Republican primary aren't ready.
Since Trump was elected,
federal spending has risen about half a trillion dollars.
It doesn't mean some of us aren't fighting.
It just means we're losing the battle.
But I think there are a lot of battles you lose in
Washington that you may be winning the hearts
and minds of people who aren't in Washington.
Are we winning hearts and minds?
That’s what I try to do with these videos,
but I wouldn’t say that we’re winning.
With socialism newly popular,
Senator Paul felt compelled to write this book
making the case against it.
More on that in another video.
But Paul says progress has been made,
and evidence of that is President Trump implementing
Senator Pauls’ free market ideas on healthcare
Let competition drive prices down.
The President said, it’s a great idea!
Paul then tweeted that he’s proud to stand with
President Trump, that together we
“cut taxes, repealed regulations,
and put better judges on the court.”
The plan is to get out of endless wars
Paul also praised the president for saying he’d
bring our soldiers home
A very bold move from President Trump,
it’s exactly what he promised the American people.
Paul tweeted
"The first president to understand
what our national interest is."
But he hasn't pulled out of anywhere.
Compare it though to George W. Bush,
who got us involved everywhere.
Or compared to President Obama,
who sent 100,000 troops to Afghanistan.
The rhetoric of President Trump has actually been,
I think, a relief.
Bring our soldiers back home,
to not be policing agents all over the world.
Has it happened yet?
No, but I continue to push
We should get out of Afghanistan
But when the president has said anything about it,
when I have supported him, immediately
the Republican leaders and the Democrat leaders
get together and they hurry,
and they immediately pass a resolution saying
it would be precipitous to leave Afghanistan.
the danger of a precipitous withdrawal.
Really after 19 years, precipitous?
[gunshot]
America went into Afghanistan to take out
the killers behind the September 11th attack.
We did that,
but we’re still there 18 years later.
You look at intervention,
after intervention, after intervention,
we haven't had the intended consequence.
We've got more chaos
Chaos erupted at an American outpost in Afghanistan
In Iraq, we took out Saddam...
Saddam Hussein captured alive
But the people who replaced him were often worse...
We got rid of Ghaddafi the dictator,
but what replaced him isn’t better.
In Syria we armed rebels to fight Assad.
But often our weapons ended up in the hands
of Al Qaeda –
Everything we think we're going to get more of,
stability or less terrorism,
we end up getting more chaos and more terrorism
So, President Trump is right, says Paul, when he says:
We want to bring our soldiers back home.
Recently, Trump moved some troops
from northern Syria
He moved 50 out of the way
and all the war hawk caucus have gone crazy
Leaving the Kurds for slaughter!
This reckless action
This is the most screwed up decision I've
seen since I've been in Congress
he had the audacity to move 50 soldiers.
And it's like, these people are insane.
A betrayal of the strongest allies
Four years ago, you said,
"The United States should arm the Kurds.
Promise them their own country.
And now, those 50 soldiers were presumably
keeping the Turks from killing the Kurds.
You've abandoned them.
When I refer to the Kurds having a homeland,
they kind of do.
They have a of section of Iraq.
I know they would wish it;
they would hope it to be a country.
But I never really have advocated that we would
mandate or protect some sort of new country
within Syria for the Kurds.
The bottom line is that the people who live there
know better about this
It's a very complicated war over there.
There’s four or five different countries involved in it.
We can't know enough about these problems.
And unless you want to put 100,000 troops in there
and fight Assad, Russia, Turkey….
We ought to rethink whether we should get involved
in these wars to begin with.
[Chopper Noise]
I promise you, 50 soldiers or 2000 American soldiers
are nothing more than a target for bad people
to kill or to maim,
which will get us drug into a bigger war.
I don’t know whether Senator Rand is right about Syria.
But 18 years of war in the Middle East,
America’s longest war ever,
hasn’t done what our leaders said it would.
We need our troops. But we should use them sparingly.
Only when we’re sure it benefits our defense.
And if we go to war,
the Constitution says Congress must vote
to declare war.
I’m glad Senator Paul argues those points.